there is no easy end to the latest
border crisis in West Texas officials in
El Paso are working to create more
temporary housing for people who
continue to arrive in the U.S shelters
are overcrowded and the travel slowdown
across the U.S is making it harder to
relocate migrants others are waiting at
the border until the Supreme Court
decides whether to end title 42 the
pandemic policy that allows migrants to
be expelled over public health concerns
Omar via Franca has more on one City's
struggle
hundreds of migrants line up outside of
Sacred Heart Church in El Paso a
facility that can hold about 100 each
night hoping for a place to sleep in
this first come first serve shelter the
line forms every day and circles the
block
those who can't get a spot or fear going
to shelters without documents sleep on
the street
[Music]
for many the weight has already been too
much to bear
uh
and the road to the U.S is becoming
increasingly dangerous according to DHS
there have been extremist calls for
attacks targeting migrants should title
42 ever be lifted this includes the
placement of landmines along migration
routes and poisoning migrants with gas
Hernandez says she traveled alone from
El Salvador to free violence and police
corruption in the country she hopes to
find work in Fort Worth and help her
family with Crossing into the U.S
all she asks of officials
Hernandez is staying at the Annunciation
house charity in El Paso where Ruben
Garcia is the director they risk their
lives and now that they're here they're
finding that they can't ask for Asylum
and that's just truly truly
tragic El Paso officials are preparing
for another uptick in migrant border
crossings
U.S border officials announced plans to
establish a tent facility outside of El
Paso to hold roughly 1 000 migrants
starting next month and city leaders are
working to prepare two schools to house
migrants
for CBS mornings I'm Omar villafranca
Dallas